[MUSIC]
Okay. So now, we have our freshly printed website.
I'm going to go ahead and clean things up a little bit, so
we're only looking at what our mock up should be.
Get rid of these extra colors and get rid of this extra margin on the side.
[SOUND] So
now, I'm going to go ahead and cut this up into a bunch of different boxes.
So you can see to start out, we have three main boxes.
One for our header.
One for the middle image and one for the bottom images.
[SOUND] But there's actually a lot
more than just three boxes here.
Looking at the header again, we have two more boxes.
One for the you and another for our name and title.
So let's cut those out.
We still have our single image in the middle here.
But looking at our bottom featured work section, we actually have another box
for our header and then three more boxes around our images and captions.
And you could actually keep cutting these up into more boxes.
We have another box around our images.
Another box around our titles.
Another around the URLs.
But my hand is kind of cramping from all that cutting, so
I'm just going to stop here.
Now as we just saw, I printed out the page and I cut it up with scissors.
But obviously, you could have done any of these and it would have worked out.
And you also should have found between 9 and 20 boxes depending on
how deep you went and how much you just love drawing boxes around things